foreign
tells of an ancient book so evil and so
vile that it could summon the dead
reading these cursed passages brings
only Madness and suffering but to truly
summon the forces of evil one must look
beyond the bounds of the blood Inked
images into the space between the void
where true Darkness lies in weight
plotting to seduce you to its ungodly
ways and convince you to watch Beast
Wars
this evil resides within the gutter
space the only pop culture news show
hosted in front of a live studio hostage
the trailer for Evil Dead Rises out and
it looks fantastic I have high
expectations that this scene with the
cheese grater will become instantly
iconic and hopefully Infamous the idea
of a normal family living in the city
dealing with deadites and finding the
book is something new that we haven't
seen in an evil dead movie before an
entire apartment building is a lot of
ground to cover when the forces of evil
at work so it's a great setting just
look how impossible it seemed to get out
of that tiny cabin I'd be surprised if
any of these characters can actually
make it down the hallway successfully
let alone to the first floor
I just wish the Necronomicon prop in
this one looked a little bit cooler
because it's just kind of a big old book
made of ham
bringing the series back to its horror
roots and easing up on the comedy while
still hopefully retaining some Camp
sounds like a good direction to go I'm a
huge fan of Evil Dead and I'll always
maintain that the 2014 remake is just as
good as the rest of the franchise even
without Ash Williams and if you're
desperate for a more army of
darkness-esque Legacy continuation about
ash good news you got 30 episodes of
that even though everyone pirated it to
death but don't worry none of you are
guilty it was deep it was only the most
illegally downloaded TV show
foreign
I understand Bruce's resentment that
some of you punks didn't support the
show's official release resulting in its
cancellation so if you're salty that
Evil Dead content is coming out without
Ash Williams it's really our own fault
for not trying harder to keep that show
up and running sure it sucks because
he's such a great character but there's
been enough Evil Dead style content
without him that I can comfortably say
the series can evolve past the character
just go watch that Creep Show episode
with Ted Ramey and an obvious Bob Ross
parody is the main hero it works just as
well
you know and then the the Remake all I'm
really hoping for from this new
installment is some kind of connection
back to the 2014 movie with a return
appearance from Mia Allen I feel like
this is in that same universe because
like
the deadites got the different eyes
instead of the pure white ones like the
other stuff I don't know hell you could
always just bring back Kelly and Pablo
from the TV show if you want to confirm
that these are all in the same universe
somehow
continuity has always been kind of fast
and loose for evil dead so the sky's the
limit we have plenty of cool
protagonists to choose from outside of
the Jefe if you want to hear me talk
more about Evil Dead stuff go check out
mine and Diego's massive retrospective
on all the Evil Dead games we even got
Bruce and his son Andy to have some
cameos in that video in 2020 there were
over 5 million car crashes that's more
than 15 000 a day and six hundred an
hour just back in December my own dad
slid off an icy Road and broke his hip
in four places and the thought of
getting legal help was so daunting for
him
those in an accident can be entitled to
more than you think when something like
that happens it's always good to have
someone in your corner looking out for
your best interest someone like the fine
folks at Morgan and Morgan if you've
been in an accident there are certain
things you need to do make sure you're
okay make sure you get a police report
make sure you contact your insurance and
make sure you get legal representation
so if you're injured and don't know
where to start with Morgan and Morgan
it's so easy Morgan and Morgan have
modernized injury law by making the
process as easy and streamlined as
possible so you can submit a claim in
eight clicks or less no need for you to
visit law offices and sit through timely
consultations you can submit a claim and
have a lawyer review your case and get
started on helping you right away you
can submit your case details sign
contracts upload documents and medical
records all from your cell phone and you
can even text your attorney and legal
team throughout the duration of your
case with Morgan and Morgan you can
submit a claim without ever having to
leave the couch if you're ever injured
in an accident you can check out Morgan
and Morgan for more information go to
forthepeople.com or pound law that's
pound529 from your cell phone now back
to the video the other thing I love but
don't talk about often enough on the
channel is Transformers particularly
[Music]
it was the series I grew up with and
what got me interested in that world and
characters so it's surreal to see them
being adapted in the big budget live
action Transformers world I think it's a
shame that none of the original beast
wars voice cast made it into the movie
except for that guy who played depth
charge but it probably has something to
do with all them being Canadian va's and
this being an American production and
Union rules or something Ron Perlman has
played Optimus primal in the past so
they at least looked for someone that
could be a returning voice but my heart
will always be with Mr chalk I'm not
totally jazzed about having G1
characters and Beast Wars era characters
directly crossing over and interacting
again because they're supposed to be
separated by several centuries and
effectively act as different subsections
of the franchise but these movies need
Bumblebee and Optimus Prime as Mainstays
to sell so I'm sure the Beast guys will
travel in from the future to pull a Star
Trek 09 and reboot the timeline so the
Bay movies never happened
which would be pretty funny did you
remember that Unicron is the Earth and
if he transforms it would kill everyone
I'm curious how they'll explain in the
movie you know why they're animals
instead of cars because the show did a
pretty good job of that but this story
is completely different so we'll see
speaking of Transformers news after a
two decade run and some of the most
important stories in the franchise IDW
has unfortunately lost the license to
publish Transformers Comics due to low
sales
man they had it all Transformers Ninja
Turtles and Sonic it was the full
Trifecta of things autistic people love
I hear their sonic stuff
I hear their Sonic and Turtle stuff is
doing pretty well though so they at
least have most of that market cornered
I'm curious who could become the new
comic home of Transformers it'd be
really ironic if they ended up back at
Marvel after all these years I've been
saying for years that I want more comic
book themed games with cel-shaded art
style instead of photorealism other than
that Telltale schlock and we finally
have a new Hellboy game delivering on
that just look at Ultimate Spider-Man
that still holds up the blocky and
angular character models with heavy pure
black inking Shadows evoke so much of
the look of Mike mignola's comics and
this character was a perfect choice to
render in this art style plus Lance
Reddick voicing red is a great choice
maybe one of these days it would be fun
to cover all the various Hellboy games
from over the years since he's had quite
a few appearances I can dress up Diego
as a cigar chomping devil detective with
filed down horns I bet he'd be down as
for superhero games with photorealistic
art styles that all look the same
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
will feature Kevin Conroy's final
performance as The Dark Knight it's a
shame it'll be in a project where he's
like a mind-controlled bad guy but I do
think it's a little poetic that it would
be Arkham Batman for his last outing in
such a legendary career I hope in the
boss fight with him he does the cape
stun and beat down on the player to give
you an instant game over because that
would be pretty funny new spider verse
footage never in a million years did I
think Spectacular Spider-Man or
Spider-Man Unlimited would be featured
in a high budget theatrically released
movie in the year 2023 together I don't
have much to say about the trailer other
than that this isn't PS1 Spider-Man what
the hell are you guys talking about and
I'm happy to see miles back in Action
because the first movie made me love and
appreciate the character when I didn't
previously uh you know what it's also
fun to see a married Peter Parker with a
child in a big mainstream movie because
now Marvel editorial will have an even
harder time pretending that should never
happen in the comics mayday's going to
be popular you [__] you can't do
anything to stop it Deadpool 3 will be a
crossover with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
I I it's been so long since we've done
an episode of this that like I I'm
pretty sure I didn't talk about that
that is the oldest news God damn it he
better wear the suit finally that
beautiful dehydrated effeminate
Australian Adonis Ant-Man 3 is going for
a more Grand epic massive route for its
story director Peyton Reed says he wants
to be the one doing the big explosion
movie instead of the pallet cleanser but
I always felt that the smaller scope was
the most appealing thing about the
Ant-Man movies
so it's kind of sad to lose that but you
know now it's like setting up King the
Conqueror for multiple Avengers movies
and it's pretty much exclusively on
green screens the Spy Kids 3 Sharkboy
and Lava Girl accusations are pretty
founded but I'm just happy to see that
Kang has a funny blue face purple face I
don't know I'm really colorblind
Modoc is a big floating head I've been
pretty burned out on MCU stuff lately
and have been enjoying their recent
projects less and less say for
Spider-Man but I'll give this one a shot
because you know Scott Lang is a really
fun character and Kang looks pretty cool
and I don't know I just
like when she [__] Daredevil the DC
movie Universe imploded James Gunn and
some other guy forgot his name are
basically restarting the entire thing
from scratch and recasting everyone
they're dumping the old continuity and
starting over Marvel may need to do this
same thing in 10 years once people start
jonesing for more Iron Man and Captain
America content as a fan of Ninja
Turtles Transformers Sonic and cartoon
superheroes in general I'm quite used to
this sort of thing I don't think any
movie or animated continuity should run
indefinitely especially when most have
said continuity kind of sucks because
the studio keeps meddling with it and
has no Clear Vision for what they want
to do
first it's Snyder's thing then they lost
faith in him and sabotaged all of that
and then it was a few years of just
throwing everything at the wall and then
it was like Dwayne Johnson's thing for
like six months and then he seemed to be
unclear who Black Adam is a villain for
so he kept pushing for a plot line that
didn't make any sense because ego won't
allow him to play a character that loses
to a 14 year old then they just threw
the whole thing out having Henry show up
for that short Superman Cameo for a
glimpse of Hope just a booting back out
again within the same month was really
brutal and terrible but at this point
I'm just so tired of these movies being
such a sideshow that I'll take a fresh
start if you're not going to let Snyder
do his thing and you're also not going
to let Johnson do his thing then just
give up and stop trying to play with
toys in someone else's box make your own
Batman and Superman and Flash in one
room in an Aquaman and do whatever you
want with them Warner Brothers because
like [__] man this is just not working
Zachary Levi however continues to say
silly [__] on social media with full
confidence implying that he's not going
to be recast and rebooted but like the
studio is not going to say they're
dropping the cast of a movie that hasn't
come out yet because they still need to
sell those tickets Shazam 2 and the
Flash are foregone conclusions since
they're too expensive to throw in the
trash like Batgirl and they've already
had some marketing so people are aware
that those will come out those will drop
and then we'll get the news that those
actors are out which is sad because you
know Jason Momoa is pretty cool I get I
mean there's rumors that he might be
Lobo which all right sure fair enough
frankly adapting Flashpoint is one of
the last movies in the series may be a
happy accident so they can just end it
with a new timeline being jump started
so they like canonize the reboot as
something that happens in the story kind
of like how they did that whole run of
lightly connected animated movies for a
little while in the late 2000s then did
Flashpoint to start that DC animated
movie universe that ran for like 10
years that was a lot more clean with its
continuity then when that ran its course
they just had the Flash start them over
again for the current thing having flash
as a character is an easy reboot button
if your story gets [__] up so you're
lucky to have him Indiana Jones 5 is a
thing digital D aging looks better and
better every year this is a different
kind of dag this is actual
archival footage of film of me at that
age
so it's not it's not that it's a
different process I'm not like a super
huge Indie fan but this looks pretty
cool though I
think I should go back through and play
all the Indiana Jones games more gutter
space will come out in 2023 as long as
new stupid stuff keeps getting announced
I have a lot of videos to plan including
more crossovers with my pals Muzzy and
Diego thank you guys for watching the
ever loving hell out of that Ultimate
Spider-Man video because it is now the
most successful video launch on the
entire Channel it meant a lot to see
something really blow up and go huge
after a bit of a slump for the past few
months surely this gutter Space video
will do even better right I always get
mad at YouTube for not putting my videos
in the subscription box because people
will comment finally Xavier uploads
again after all these years not knowing
three other videos came out within the
last month already so maybe that stupid
Bell icon thing will help you remember I
exist if you want other ways to support
the channel you can always go hit up
that patreon for early videos and
exclusive stuff because it's just a
dollar I'm not kidding it's only one
dollar Isn't that cool
if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator code Xavier GM next time
you buy a silly dancer cool character
skin really helps me out
see you next time
foreign
[Music]